all right ladies and gentlemen you're
now tuning in to the league podcast we
just did bootleg Kev interview's about
to go crazy if you feel away just know
we talked about it you feel me and it's
all displayed for everybody to listen to
so I know you're going to tune in don't
get it twisted get it right it's elite
Pockets the hottest podcast on it the
hottest
yo bootle cat podcast man special guests
in here I'm gonna let you guys introduce
yourselves you guys have a podcast
called The Lick leak leak it's leak you
know why I say the lick because it looks
like liquor well also because the
alcoholics but the licks were Li K yeah
so it's the leak my name is Kalik Scott
colleek colleague Scott all the homies
call me leak so this is the leak podcast
drip like water like wet okay so game
licking [__] we ain't looking [__] so
it's short for colleague click yeah all
my homies call me league so that's how
it came to the league pocket okay and
then this is yike Mike who you're a DJ
yeah a DJ producer graphic designer
everything all that yeah and the co-host
of the league podcast so uh how long has
this podcast been active uh since 2018
we started well [__] that's amazing yeah
yeah I I I like checked out some of you
guys the stuff on YouTube and I I was
like okay you guys are like throwing
live parties yeah [__] got kind of
intense yeah like I saw like just a
stream of like ass just like
strippers and deep and you're DJing and
like
I'm like okay well this is different
yeah and then I saw you guys obviously
do your interviews and stuff as well but
like how would you describe
I guess your podcast
um it's a it's a lifestyle podcast we do
life with people and um I was doing this
uh since 2018 and I really found like uh
if you watched our first episode that's
on our YouTube yeah I did what everybody
does get a bunch of homies get a bunch
of mics and just wait for magic to
happen right and I realize nobody knows
how to really talk and everybody just
kind of sits there and waits right so I
said all right let's go back to the
drawing board so I went back started uh
uh just looking at what their issues
were what the problems were the main
issues were the look The Sound The
Branding all that stuff so then I took
some time off came up with the
rebranding and then we did the whole
Simpson Vibe the whole Simpson Vibe is
like people [__] with it just by looking
at it yeah yeah they don't even have to
hear it and they're already like yo I
[__] with your podcast so the sense cool
with the couch yeah so we did all that I
rebuilt the whole Simpson set so that
was like a quick eye Grabber the logo
everything all that stuff and then I was
on this uh journey of doing what
everybody else is doing get the artist
get the influencers bring them in talk
to them do all that stuff or whatever
and then I got tired of talking to those
people because I feel like a lot of them
don't really know how to conversate
themselves they just want to come on the
couch and get their dick stroked right
you feel me like let me just get my
Clips to look
you know however they need to look on
the ground so I went on the journey when
I did a lot of big names uh interviewed
a lot of big people
uh got a lot of good traction but I felt
like I was working harder and not
smarter and so once I got tired of that
um
I I'm like friends with like DJs that
play in Hollywood yeah like Mike he
plays a lot of these Mansion parties and
stuff like that so when we're going out
I'm giving these DJs my drop for the
podcast and I'm like well we're here
play this bro just play my drop in
Hollywood right so all that stuff is
happening in Hollywood we're going crazy
in Hollywood as it is with our own
circle of friends and the girls and all
this other stuff that we're doing
so uh we were doing the interview stuff
and we wanted to get into like the live
stream world and the one thing that
everybody says to me when they come over
to the studio is damn you don't see all
this on camera like all the room and
everything and so I just took time to
say okay we're gonna go live it has to
we have to show the whole room in the
live it has to be different than the
episodes you know and so when I decided
to do that I said well let's just do
everything we're doing right now in
Hollywood and these parties and these
mansions and let's just do it on live
stream I didn't want to do it like
everybody else right you gotta be so we
started doing it and it started off with
one DJ and one stripper and then we went
six months uh the second episode
uh uh the stripper that was on the show
I literally had a conversation with her
I said look just give me six months stay
down for the come up and I guarantee you
will be in a different place we just
have to hit every week for six months
right and she said I'm with it and so we
did that and [__] went crazy and it just
snowballed and it snowballed and it
snowballed until the last episode the
season finale we had to stop because the
neighbors the cops people were banging
on the door it's not just a party on
camera it's a party party yeah the
streets they're shooting music videos in
there's convertibles with ass being
thrown and my neighbors are just like
[__] is this at your house yeah oh so
you do that at the crib garage yeah I
wake up and cook
so what is your history like just what
do you do outside of the podcast like I
mean obviously you just don't well I'm a
creative so I've always created prior to
this I was doing music videos for
artists so I was traveling editing music
videos and shooting music videos
um ghost editing getting hard drive sent
to me for like labels and [__] like that
um so I was doing that like I said uh I
did one podcast with my friend Ziggy and
the thing I got out of that podcast was
what you put out is what you're gonna
get back for 100 so I was putting out
these music videos and I wasn't putting
out enough podcast content so once I got
tired of that lane or that field and all
that stuff I said [__] that like I'm
over it let's just these people are
paying me to look big right so I say let
me just stop making them look big and
make myself look big real quick and so
that's what we did and we ran it up and
it's been going crazy and and are you
editing everything yourself
it's been edited in real time oh it's
like switcher yeah yeah once it's done
it's done because it's my crib I have
time but even like when you guys do
interviews yeah I know what about like
your social Clips are you making those
yourself yeah yeah yeah yeah I didn't
know if it's like you doing it no I do
it okay okay Mike does it we cut up we
really cook that's what I'm saying
that's the difference between I guess us
and these other podcasts they either
don't know how to cook or they just
Outsource it right or they just let
somebody figure it out with us we're
sending Clips back and forth we're
sitting there until three in the morning
after the podcast sending Clips on the
laptop like yo this shit's crazy use
that let me use that clip let me use
that you like that clip bad bam I got
this effect
voiceovers for his social posts later on
yeah so you told me uh off camera you
said that uh because you said that you
had an interview with my friend RJ yeah
yeah yeah and his lady is Bree Carter
who's got a new project out she's doing
music she's been doing music yeah she
was just on the show no now you said
that you had um you didn't know that
that was his girl
you had no idea no idea so you walked
into that interview not knowing that no
I didn't walk into you but I'm saying
but you had asked you had asked some
questions that had you known yeah you
wouldn't have asked probably
um not that I wouldn't have asked I
probably still would have asked because
like the whole premise of the show we
talk about relationships right I
probably would have just let things
slide when I look back at it it's like I
said it we moved on and then I doubled
down on it and that's when it was like
hey yo and I'm like it's kind of what we
do here well what you said was your
superpower is not knowing my the
unknowing is my superpower so what does
that mean
um I just asked like I think a lot of uh
I go to a lot of these events one of the
things we do different than a lot of
these other podcasts is we go to these
functions we go to these events and we
do interviews with artists and and you
know we're in the face with artists
um and so a lot of the times and one of
the reasons I have yike Mike and Jr and
these dudes around me is because they're
in that they know yeah so the people
were around they're like yo go holla at
him go holla at him and I'm like all
right bet what's up I don't got a
problem talking to people I'm a people
person and so like there's interviews
where people have come to me after like
yo you asked him this that's crazy and
I'm like I don't know I didn't know
better yeah I didn't know why it's crazy
I just asking them questions like you
know but I feel like that that's my
superpower I don't know too much about
these artists because I don't have time
to study like right I'm literally like
I'm almost like a dog when you know a
dog sniffs ass and they just kind of
figure out what what's what what's up
with you that's how I am with people I'm
like what's up with you what do you do
what are you on what's popping all right
what's moving all right cool bet on next
yeah what do you got going on okay cool
that's I am with people you know so so I
know that uh the day in L.A homie had
did a uh La rapper report card yeah yeah
yeah and uh what made you want to do uh
LA area podcast report card uh it's
marketing yeah it's just marketed like
for like I said me and Mike we cook
right I cook like I design I'm with the
laptop keep working on this huh how long
did it take for you to put this together
uh week okay yeah you said this was LA
area podcast report card that's what it
looks like right nah usconnect is IE
base
I'm talking about Southern California
yeah it is a California Southern
California yeah it's a Southern
California yeah well for me I like I
didn't really look at it like uh like
location based I just looked like over
here on this side of town what's what
are some of the the outlets that are
making noise and have influence over
here on this side so I didn't really
look at like boundaries so I don't
really know where all these are located
right but I didn't go I didn't go to
like the podcast I know in the east
coast no no I mean the way I looked at
this was I looked at it as like the way
uh is his name DeJean yeah DeJean the
way he did uh the LA reporter I was like
oh this is like a obviously Southern
California base report card right yeah
yeah so I see you guys got all tens
which is expected because it is your
report card somebody commented it was
like you can't create your own [__] I
said I can't
you should grade your own [__]
um so I'm looking at this uh report card
and uh the one thing I can say is I
never met you guys or spoke to you guys
ever before so when I got tagged in this
report card
I was like I'm always like I'm like I
don't know let's like let me take a peek
wait let me ask you this do you agree
with your grade yeah for sure
do you think like holistically like the
whole thing like this thing is off so I
think on what let's see what I say like
with stuff like this yeah everything's
opinion based subjective yeah it's
subjective right yeah yeah but I'm
saying with you you're with your opinion
do you think this is far off
like I'm not all the way
um tapped in with everybody with
everybody on this yeah which is cool
which is fair right so for me if you
look at like for the ones that you do
know like I love back on fig so I agree
with you there
um
I think uh brown bag is great so I agree
with you there
um
I haven't watched enough of Gina's stuff
to really give a grade on whole Fashions
yeah I had to do research on that but I
agree with her being a 10 personality
yeah she got a D plus overall but she
got a 10 as a personality so I could
agree with you there
I only saw what the homie watch Homie
Quan said about the Clapping up La guys
so I am very big well I'm ignorant to
their platform and I don't mean to be I
gotta check it out um but they got an F
yeah
um the day in La guy again like I'm not
I know who he is and I've seen him on
other platforms and I know he's got
certain opinions about radio that him
and I don't see necessarily eye to eye
on and I'm sure we'll talk one day
he's got a D but again I haven't watched
his podcast so I can't even Snippets
I've only seen him on no jumper what
stops you from watching the podcast like
is it time or yeah I just I had time I I
guess I'm like in my bubble so my bubble
is like my bubble is like sports
Joe Rogan
I mean it takes a lot for me to like
check out a new platform have you seen
the leaked podcast like have you watched
anything I just did I just did this week
which one I I threw on uh the AC trike
episode yeah have you seen the live
stream episode so listen China came on
take him on the podcast with [__] on his
chest that let off that was the first
time any artist came to the podcast with
[__] to get off so what I did was I was
like I just kind of looked over your
guys's Channel and I was like okay you
guys are doing these streams yeah so I
threw the stream on and I was like oh
they got strippers and [__] the DJs yeah
four angles like yeah yeah I've never
seen them like that before like it
looked cool the one thing I was worried
about is like y'all titty pops out y'all
can get demonetized yeah
this is the thing with the whole Monday
thing anyways the whole thing was for
promotion because we're playing
commercial music so we can't monetize it
anyway true but I'm saying you might get
your channel yanked you know what it
hasn't nothing seriously popped out yeah
we put like adults and all this [__]
there's I don't know if you went on
YouTube but like YG's video has full-on
naked [__] on YouTube well you know
what we we just talked about
there's a dude who went viral because he
shaved his [__] on YouTube and it's
still up it's got like 50 million yeah
yeah yeah like there's a grown man who
shaved his ass I think a lot of people
are on YouTube yeah I think a lot of
people are afraid of nudity on YouTube
but there's you can do it there's just a
way to do it so I think you just got it
so I checked out like you guys I love
the set I love how you guys recreated
The Simpsons couch looks dope
um that's dope it's in your garage too
yeah
um so it looks I mean it looks legit um
I've seen some of the 44 vato stuff
that's to do with the orange ski mask
yeah orange ski mask I like his [__]
it's cool
um I don't know who aux connect is so I
can't uh you know who DJ Charlie Cinco
is yeah
what's his platform oh yeah I like his
uh tick tocks yeah
in the LA at least right or everything
playlist
like everything and y'all getting my f
damn he hasn't dropped and why haven't
since he's off I'm on that I was on that
podcast well I also like oh okay but I
like his tick tocks I really do so you
guys did give him a social media content
you guys gave him a nine yeah so that's
fair like like well hey consistency is
important yeah but but like if if the
the social media content with the stuff
that they drop on like Instagram and the
artists like so that's fair yeah if you
give him a nine on that that makes sense
right yeah but as far as consistency
it's just not there like as far as
podcast dropping uh like a lot I mean I
love Rosecrans Ave I love Rosecrans Vic
I mean they've been kind of the LA
platform to me for a long time yeah I
think uh homegrown radio maybe could
have been a little higher but I'm biased
because DJ head is like my bro I mean he
just called me before we started this
podcast
um but again but yeah but I feel like
they're like I think consistency is
their their issue their issue yeah sure
but I feel like they're in like this not
rebranding phase but they're they're
doing different things yeah and like you
gave them like a 10 on topics eight on
personality 10 on it yeah yeah and
really an important thing is the 10 on
impact yeah and the channels I gave a
lot of tens out this this report guy got
a lot I think
I think in a lot of this [__] and I like
that the corner store freestyles but
again it's like it's a freestyle
platform from what I've seen again I'm
speaking from a place of ignorance
because that's all I've seen yeah me too
and that's why I gave the personality uh
because if you've got freestyles what
are the topics yeah but they do great
freestyles
um
let's see Community b-plus I love back
on fig I love fumunity I love their
podcast I like icon yeah and I think you
like icon I think he's great on that
podcast I don't know about him on no
jumper because no I no I'm just saying I
like him I like him as a host of the of
the the full community I just think the
energy needs to be a little bit more a
little more energy I think it's cool I
mean I think that like he's doing a good
job of yeah I like food Community
they're solid I've always spoke with
them they're a great follow
it was funny because uh I was doing a
bunch of collab posts with a bunch of
other media platforms and they uh they
collabed with me and I got somebody in
trouble over there because they hit me
after like a hour later and was like my
manager told me I can't post this
because we didn't get an A so then they
took it down and [__] oh really yeah
yeah yeah I've seen a B's respectable
yeah like you just gotta run it up no
jumper c yeah let me see what okay so
personality a five so obviously you guys
aren't aren't aren't friends of Adam
because he used the personality uh ten
no no no no no no no seven no but no
jumper it's not just Adam it's everybody
that's there you're right yeah so I'll
give you that yeah because I do think
there are certain guys on their channel
that aren't great yeah
and they're trying to find that hey
that's fair that's a fair assessment
shout out to Brick baby who's amazing he
just uh he's here actually right now
there's some people that are solid some
people that just looks like they're
trying to figure it out and just I do
think they're really good I think you
gave them a four on social media content
but I feel like they're they pump out
content on social media a lot yeah but I
don't think that it's not just posting
it's back in the day they were like the
lead of the culture where you went to
them for new flavor now it's just
internet mess okay you get me it's not
no it's not about their podcast anymore
uh why
do you guys I'm assuming that the DeJean
guys not happy with this
D did you see the cover photo
I saw her he's holding it I saw that
crazy what do you think about that
I mean I thought it was kind of funny
that's the post I saw because I think I
was tagged it or something yeah yeah so
I thought it was cool yeah but what do
you think he thought I thought he hated
it for sure why would he hate it though
because he did the LA report card yeah
but it is good it's him it's we're
promoting him yeah he's the brand of the
report card so we got to do all respects
and this is the podcast you guys did pay
homage to him in that way basically
homage ah yeah but I photoshopped his
hand to hold his own report did he DM
you guys or anything no he reposted
somebody's tweets online so he reposted
somebody's tweet that said
um it ain't valid if it's not DeJean
doing the report card or something like
that and that's all I've really heard of
it but yeah
everybody in my comments is tagging them
everybody around me that's the crazy
part I haven't been blocked but Grime
face got blocked all these other people
that follow him jack Mike nah I'll
message his own I made his intro for his
whole podcast the beat I made that I'm
done like Mike's a great name by the way
yeah I'm the one and only so yeah hey
that's a sick name what's your name yike
Mike [__] I'm gonna use that as
a tag I got that uh that kind of tag No
Cap all right but you guys gave me an a
which I appreciated uh I guess I don't
really uh yeah I mean thanks yeah and
I'll tell you why because uh there's
some people that hit me up and try to
make this like a race because we don't
know each other yeah we don't know each
other at all I never ever spoken to
either of you guys at all I never
followed you before this it was an
unbiased thing it's an unbiased thing
and I'm gonna tell you why because to me
watching from the outside
um I don't sit here and watch every
episode on lighting if I did that but
the clips that you do post and the
interviews that you do get I feel like
for the culture they're impactful
they're big names they mean something
The Branding is here it's consistent
when everybody fell off with podcasting
everybody wants to start a podcast and
one thing I tell everybody that tells me
oh I want to start a podcast I said good
luck the hardest part about podcasting
isn't these cameras isn't any any of
this [__] the hardest part is
consistency in swimming consistency and
the fact that you've been doing it for
so long to me I feel like you're the
West Coast version of like Funk Flex I
appreciate it you get me like he's just
a known staple and artists know they go
over there to wrap they go over there to
check in they go over there go over
there to do that and it's been a flag
that's been over here consistently you
know where people aren't like oh it was
here for a little bit and then where did
it go he's out there trying to figure it
out right now or he's doing other things
and he got another deal over here so his
podcast is suffering for it and right
it's always been consistent so from the
outside I'm like that would be someone
where I could be like yeah like that
that would be a good model to follow for
anybody podcast well I appreciate it man
yeah yeah definitely yeah I was like I
was like oh [__] I don't even know these
guys I'm the only
but see that's the thing some people try
to make it make it a racial thing I
didn't even see I haven't seen any of
the commentary about my grade so there
has been people saying that oh my DM's
crazy I'm trying to Dick ride I gave
full Unity a good grade because I want
to meet them and I'm a fan of them and I
need them and I graded uh other other
platforms higher grades than the black
ones and so I'm disrespecting the black
community you know I didn't look at
color I looked at quality yeah I like
that quality sound like sound is a big
issue for a lot of these platforms
trying to figure it out for sure
straight up and a lot of the things that
people don't value it shows production
value production value is crazy and a
lot of them got a bad grade in my eyes
because it's the same setup it's a round
Table Right with microphones or a flat
wall that doesn't look interesting and
they just think if I talk people will
listen nobody everybody wants to podcast
and do all this stuff the same exact way
like everybody wants to be a clone well
I will say this like that was one thing
because I'm not sure
um you guys partying on stream is a
podcast
reviews
very original wait but did you wait wait
did you watch
episode okay okay
it's on the podcast watch a full episode
right we are the first platform to give
strippers a voice not sit there and
exploit them right not sit there and say
shake that ass [__] I want to get in
that [__] right no right the turn up is
a byproduct of our lifestyle so what we
do in our podcast is we turn up party
have a good time get everybody
comfortable then we stop get the girls
on the couch podcast Time Podcast time
talk it out when we're ready to switch
the seat back to the music everybody's
having a good time next person on the
couch well it's a really I would say
this it is extremely original yeah and
because I was saying I was telling this
to my boy uh Eric I'm like man like
these dudes is doing something I never
seen done yeah yeah but it but but
because even just like when you hit play
like imagine if like I was like yo this
is some [__] you could just have on at
the crib bro my friends are telling me
they are over there busting down trees
and breaking weed up for all these uh
what do they call it trimming or
whatever right and these guys are just
watching it they're at work and they're
just watching it it's just something to
put on yeah you could just listen to it
the music selection is already fire like
you know you need ox cord in the in the
you have your homies you gotta kick back
you can just throw on the mix and the
podcast a lot of people get a lot of
people got lost in the ass but what they
don't realize is that these same girls
are with us for six months straight
every Monday so we're there every Monday
so they're just regularly we have a team
I got 11 girls that got the podcast
tatted on them
I saw it online I just saw that I just
saw somebody at the I was like yo check
that out on Livestream 11 girls on live
stream got tatted yeah and so my thing
is is that
it's like a road trip you ever been on a
road trip with somebody like a long one
and somebody who didn't know that well
by the end of the road trip you're like
I kind of know this guy and I know why I
[__] with him and I know why I don't
[__] with him right and so the six
months was a long ass road trip with
these girls and so we I we nobody was
rushing to [__] these girls we just took
time to get to know him we respected him
we took time to get to know him there's
a problem most time people bring
strippers around because eventually you
want to try to [__] yeah but but but but
my thing is they're on the couch saying
thank you nobody's ever just heard us
out nobody's ever tried to figure us out
they just the strippers get a really bad
misrepresentation but but one thing I
realized in doing the Pod was that
stripping is just like working at
Starbucks I agree fully it's just like
they don't give a [__] about you it is a
little job it's a literal job their job
is to kind of be your counselor or make
you feel like they like you yeah that is
their literal profession my job is to
make you feel like I like you yeah yeah
and if you feel that way you're gonna
give me some money and then then you're
going to go home to your wife and then
I'm going to get off of work and go home
to my boyfriend or my kids or whatever
it's just it is what it is yeah they're
they're half naked counselors or naked
counselors and so a lot of some of the
girls like uh we went from the stripper
thing and then other girls started
catching wind of it and then we brought
in some 304s that are actually on fig
and [__] like that they're coming in and
telling their story so it gets deep
there was one girl that was off the
block was like damn is this church or a
podcast like what the [__] going on
crazy we have deep conversation on there
but you got to get past the ass I'm
gonna dive in yeah you got to get past
that I was in bro like I said I love the
presentation and I really just like the
uh
it's hard to see originality yeah so to
me it was like so do you agree with my
grade or not uh from what you've seen
for yourself yeah
like is there something that you've seen
that you disagreed with as far as
content as far as impact as far as
branding consistency topics okay this is
what I would say there's something you
don't know about yeah I'm very like I
said I kind of skim through your [__] I
think
um
I like your branding
uh I like the originality
um great production value
You're Building community
I don't know much about the topics
because I haven't really seen too much
to give you that I mean look this is
your [__] report card
be honest
be honest because because the the I
would say maybe impact would be high
um why would you say that I think just
because like when I think of impact I
think of I think a homegrown radio like
I think of like you know what does that
mean yeah what does that mean so in my
opinion impact to me would be like
the impact on either an artist's
trajectory right so if you're helping
like break artists and like you can go
back and like see well [__]
you know when I think DJ had and Chuck
did a Kendrick interview and like you
know I mean I had one in 2011 I think
they had one in 2010.
um I think impact is I maybe look at
that as more of like a a longevity like
did I make somebody no not even that
your lives like for me for me impact I
think you've had impact on people who
are on your show right these girls and
like maybe changing like the narrative
on strippers and [__] but again I'm
speaking from not the most yeah you know
uh I think impact to me though is like
like if I were to look at this hey let
me ask you this okay let me ask you this
have you ever has anybody ever cried on
this show like tears
yes how many people have cried on this
show
um
one
so so to me that's different because to
me to me that's topics no that's not
topics because what I'm thinking
impacting somebody's life yesterday we
brought in the artist because we do
music reviews on Wednesdays right this
artist sent this music in we did a
review we liked it so we brought them in
the studio yesterday we played his music
because we [__] with it we brought him
in we're playing this stuff what do you
tell you on the couch yesterday while
we're playing this stuff he was like
this is getting a little emotional right
now like y'all really like genuine so I
think that's like to me like when I
think of impact I think of like
okay if we're talking about like La
culture right what are the what are the
synonymous platforms that have been here
the longest right so to me when I think
of like a homegrown radio I'm like oh
[__] homegrown has an impact that has
been here for so long and they've done
so much to help you know they have
moments in like La hip-hop history is
there any clips of anybody and I want
you all to know this I'm looking at this
strictly through a hip-hop lens so
that's just the time thing you're saying
that's based on like how long they've
been around but see this isn't this
isn't just off of hip-hop because so so
I'm looking at this I'm looking at this
because I'm A hip-hop guy you know I'm
hip-hop too so so when I look at this
I'm thinking of 44 Balto doesn't he
covers other stuff news and all this
stuff but so when I look at this I'm I
mean listen show some love that's uh uh
what's your name Telly Spencer it's a
love podcast it doesn't have anything to
do yeah but what I was going to say was
like I I mean look because I'm thinking
that this is like the LA rapper report
card yeah we're looking at kind of the
same way so I'm like when I think of
impact I think of like I'm looking at
impact through hip-hop lens now the
impacts you might have on your guests
is different right so I'll give you that
like that's if that's the the lens
you're looking at it through like then
yeah I mean if you have people crying
and you're changing people's lives and
um and then I feel like I look down and
I'm trying to see who else
had low impact just so I could have some
sort of
so like let me give you an example right
the category of impact yeah
when I see no jumpers got a seven
but I see the impact of no jumper
created
two of the B and B plus platforms on
this so if you think about no jumper
from no jumper back on fig and Community
were born is that is that a safe thing
to say uh because neither of them would
have been doing content I mean they'll
listen yeah yeah yeah they'll tell you
third thing to say first thing to say so
to me that's
that's a big impact because if no jumper
yeah but I think yeah but I guess it
just depends on the lens you're looking
at each one of these no so so for impact
for me I feel like the no jumper
category I felt like they were high but
with re this is a recent this is recent
this isn't based off of past things that
happen a year ago or six months ago or
whatever this is today right and so with
everything with falling apart like not
his he did a whole orgy on his uh I saw
that thing so I mean it's not like his
platform is hurting he's empowered he's
elsewhere right it's still successful
but as far as culturally what everybody
went there for it lost a lot of points
because it's not what it's for sure it's
not what it used to it's not what it
used to be at all it's not but it's not
hurting I'm not saying it's not what it
used to be size-wise I'm saying it's not
what it used to be in terms of what
people expected yeah yeah yeah he
switched he switched to go to no jumper
to find out about the hot SoundCloud
rappers now you go to November just for
you know whatever what do you go there
for I just like to hear him and whack
talk
um I think Rosecrans Vic and those guys
have had some you got them at a nine on
impact because I think Rosecrans Ave has
done a lot to help push the LA hip-hop
culture and and uh just to speak on
Rosecrans
he's he does a lot of footwork oh for
sure
it's active bro and he's on this twice
because he's a part of brown bag and and
the thing about it is what I respect
about Rosecrans I'd be out at these
events and he he had not only is he
there but he has a team of people out
there doing media for his brand 100 so
it's bigger than like you get me there's
a lot of people that that are missing on
the work no Rosecrans is great he's a
great definitely and he's a part of
brown bag which is uh one of my favorite
platforms yeah it just gets kind of iffy
with me when you start breaking up the
brands so let me ask you this what is uh
okay you have an F on here two F's D oh
oh yeah you got aux connect clap it up
LA and uh day in La yeah
do you do you uh
is it because y'all got beef with these
guys are you truly I got no beef with
nobody in this world I go to bed every
night with like happy I'm from the
suburbs I don't beef we're not home
where are you from from the IE Rancho
okay yeah try to Rancho Cucamonga also
tell them shout out to yay stride we
going crazy I see the quarterback from
Texas
I hope he's terrible this year because
we on the first round pick for the
Texans I'm a Cardinals fan I'm a
Cardinals fan boy man no I mean look I
think this is dope I think it's there's
no there's no beef I just let me say
this too the one cool thing about this
is it went viral and for whatever reason
everybody on this list got new exposure
straight up so even if you are somebody
like uh you know the biggest Bros I
gotta check them out cause I've never
heard of it the biggest Bros is uh uh
what is it house phone and blasi oh
that's them them that's their that's
their platform I've seen their [__] yeah
and Yuri in them yeah yeah yeah okay
okay so yeah I didn't bro I didn't
realize that and the crazy part about
these other like biggest Bros whole
Fashions and the community and all that
I feel like and then well then for real
then no jumper has
three platforms on here that Spawn from
yeah but uh but these smaller platforms
I feel like when they left no jumper
they had to figure it out on their own
yeah for sure you feel me like prior to
them leaving no jumper it was just
showing up and talk I do love I mean I
mean uh uh back on fig is one of my
favorite shits to watch I love uh
uh uh I don't know the other guy's name
um but he has a really good personality
makwap uh he's in the little room
is all the dude in the little room he's
with the computer they have the the uh
strippers in there too
wait on what platform on the uh uh uh
yeah um
I don't know his name Ace boys yeah Ace
boys so that's pun yeah pun's like the
older dude with the glasses yeah yeah
his personality is amazing my pun's
great [__] with it yeah and he's got the
they got the yam cam going they always
got chicks pulling out their cheeks on
YouTube so you guys have that in common
whole fashion shout out to Gina uh yeah
I think at the end of the day there's no
way you're gonna do this list and not
offend somebody yeah but I think I I
think what uh just like yeah it's just
there's just no way yeah but but
everybody thinks they deserve an A plus
true but
every one of these podcasts
what they do on their podcast is talk
about other people this is the first
time anybody's ever talked about
podcasts in a group and that's what's
offensive by it but you can't be
offended by it if you do it every day
right about all these other artists and
everything going on my thing is I just
like to do things that nobody's doing I
got tired of just covering artists
because there's enough people that do
that you get me we're going to talk to
the artists and they're going to be part
of what we're doing but I'm going to do
things that people aren't doing and when
everybody's going left we're gonna go
right yep and everybody's going right
we're gonna go left yep and this is what
this is I just put the spotlight on them
you don't think it's bad do you think do
you agree that we should be keeping like
how Dijon had the artist report card the
whole goal is to make West Coast Music
you feel me get everybody to get better
just like the platforms that are
covering these artists the platforms
need to get these artists and cover them
and so we can get you know back up and
you don't think it's wrong to hold these
platforms accountable just like we hold
these artists accountable I don't even
think you're holding them accountable I
just think this is a cool idea
you know why because I put so much time
and effort into what we do and I feel
like
there's these artists that are blinded
by just going and getting content that
they don't give a [__] how it looks
right they're just like all right give
me a mic I need a camera and I need to
look like I'm getting interviewed
people that go get interviewed they
don't keep these people accountable at
all to me when you dive into like the
specific categories like you know like
the corner store guy like you got them
tanning consistency branding originality
and impact like that's dope now he's got
a C plus but that's because you know of
stuff that you're like you said like he
just needs to talk more he just needs to
have a small interview part to me it's
not even like a bad thing it's not a bad
thing no it's like that because his show
isn't that yeah and then I just know
that like the um
the Dijon kid obviously the report card
had a lot of impact if you gave him a 10
for that because he made he's yeah
he got he got hip-hop mad over here on
his side he impacted a lot of people's
lives he made people feel I think when I
think about impact I think about feeling
right you can feel good or you can feel
bad about me you feel me but if as long
as you can make people feel that's what
this is all for everybody has an opinion
but can you make somebody feel right now
this thing made people feel and so for
that and so any negatives you guys have
uh ran into with this what do you mean
negative just like anything negative
like that maybe you were like uh maybe I
burned a bridge or that like I had
people on my team say hey bro we might
burn a bridge [__] the bridge okay let's
build a boat let's [__] go like you
know what I mean hey I got a yeah no no
real [__] because at the end of the day
if these people if these people were
gonna [__] with me they would have [__]
with me right I'm not worried about
anybody giving me a handout I'm not
worried about anybody opening a door I'm
living life and I'm cooking right I'm in
here just cooking and you guys are just
getting to watch the artwork you get me
so I don't really this world is so big
this world is ginormous and I don't have
to worry about who's [__] with me and
who's not I'm just here cooking that's
all we're really doing yeah like when I
look at the like actual like categories
you know because I'm a fan of Gina yeah
so you gave her a 10 as a personality
it's like yeah that's that says you're
great yeah
her personality is amazing but I feel
like she's could the consistency be
better sure yeah the consistency but
it's not just that it's like she's with
Sway and then she's with no jumper and
then she's with well she's old Fashions
I think is her own show Yeah Yeah
official oh [__] but what I'm saying
there's no like like brand right around
like she's building the brand no but the
brand is is her name it's not an actual
like right whole fashion yeah yeah yeah
yeah I mean look man I appreciate the uh
the the Love on here I think it's
interesting because I think like you
said like you get people talking and to
me
there's something to do on the internet
and it's and if somebody is like really
offended by it it's like hey man like
one this is your opinion yeah two you
know maybe
improve yeah and just like just like uh
motion Mondays with the strippers was uh
advertisement and marketing it's the
same [__] yeah it's the same [__] the
difference is we're doing it with style
we're making fashion out of it you got
to show the comments too oh yeah people
were saying the internet is not real
life but this looks pretty real to me
yeah
thank you
yeah we got the comments on the back
yeah of course because there's love and
there's hate there's booze that's
documents
some people are haters and some people
support this is what I would say
I see the laughs okay yeah I saw her
getting graded with my rounds my
Rosecrans paper my back Brown that's
fire
um yeah I mean like I said bro I think
you guys are doing something dope I
think
people like these kind of lists are made
for people to disagree on yeah and you
know what I mean
no but this is a sport conversation it's
a smart conversation so however you feel
about it it should spark some
conversation do you think it's a
conversation that needs to happen though
I mean I think that there's people who
take this [__] extremely serious
um and I think for the most part all the
people who I'm extremely educated about
on this list do take it very serious so
yeah maybe because like at the end of
the day like you know like you know how
many people start podcasts every week or
every day and these people watch these
platforms and they do this oh I need to
do it like no jumper or I need to do it
like bootleg Kev I need to do it like
this and so my thing is if we're coming
in this game and we're taking a dead ass
serious and we're trying to be the
hottest in the game and we're trying to
do all this [__] I move more like an
artist than a podcaster and like this is
a great way to promote yourself yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah straight up because
now everybody's got to go check your
[__] out but but that's what I'm saying
like we're coming in the culture not to
change it because it's going to change
on its own but we're coming to shift it
and tilt it to where we want it to be
and the way we're doing it is by telling
people what we [__] with and what we
don't and just by us moving out there
creating content uh you know all this
[__] we just we just did a mansion party
uh in the I.E and the moment we showed
up the people were expecting us oh [__]
leak podcast in the building podcast ass
went from zero to 100 quick when we go
in a room that's impact we're the
blueprint we change like like so let me
ask you this do you think impact also
because there's there's a couple of ways
to look at impact yeah I'm looking at
impact through the lens I already told
you yeah yeah another way to look at
impact is
how does your content impact viewers
it impacts viewers because for one we're
getting into real is that I say that
because I saw what watch Homie Quan said
yeah yeah so so but if you see something
like that are you talking about the
whole black people or making it I think
I just saw what he said that like uh he
uh in regards to the Clapping up Podcast
he has said something like your [__] is
like meant for people to like I don't
want to put words in his mouth but
essentially you guys are doing parties
yeah and you there's no substance right
but if you actually watch it there is
substance there there's a video that was
posted with him coming on the podcast
and saying substance talking about God
Homie Quan yes okay he went on your
guys's podcast yeah had him on a year
ago right I mean they think it's dope
man I think you guys you know are I'll
say this Innovative man because I've
never seen anybody and it's crazy
because there's people that are like
let's say with this you know you wanna
know what this did
I we're in La we're at all these events
we we go to the pop-ups we're at the
asali store he's spinning out of Sally
for all the pop-ups that happen over
there all that [__] so we're active
we're out there in the streets doing the
footwork people that I thought [__]
with me this exposed a lot of people
that don't [__] with me and it helped me
out because it helped me cut the
[__] yeah cause worse we're shaking
hands everybody else what's up what's up
we're exposing the real and all these
people even when they come on the couch
they like this on the internet but in
real life not like that so sure uh who
would you guys say I saw ambj commented
but uh you guys [__] with Ruchi
obviously yeah uh who would you guys say
is like uh your guys's uh like you know
closest homie in the rap game when it
comes to like big like supporting like
who's your guy's biggest supporter we
got YB and namir Kai bands DB about a
bag true car radio base uh OG Maco oh
dope
um I mean [__] nimir still lives in
Riverside right uh not Riverside yeah
we got a show coming up so yeah like
right now you know you know oh you're
his DJ you know did you do my club in
Scottsdale I was looking forward to
meeting you and then you weren't there
yeah yeah
uh no scum beats he produced thotiana
load it up yeah you don't know nah never
heard you never heard of scumbies I
heard it I heard that uh yeah I don't
know what it looks like you know so
these are these are Big producers in the
game right now they're blue faces like
right main producers right now right FB
these dudes that are coming around right
now like they're tucked and we got them
popping out right now his artist are in
my DMs right now [__] what is heavy
right now because they see the motion in
what we're doing and so we went from
chasing to attracting and my thing is
I'd rather be an artist homie than just
send out a thousand DMS hey bro try to
come on my show right the content is
speaking and they're [__] with us
because we're going to come to you yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's fair based upon
what we put out so I stopped chasing I
started attracting and it's different I
love it way different oh that's dope man
hey look man I think you guys are
attracting a lot of attention with this
yeah we're basically just showing the
culture like and then if you look at
everybody that's on the show it's not
just random people we do music reviews
people sending music every Wednesday how
many times a week are you guys twice a
week Mondays yeah people sending music
we got DJs Engineers we have people that
come on and we actually give an actual
opinion and not just give an opinion we
tell them critique how to get better and
what to do since we're DJs if we like
the song we invite them on the couch
right like TV uh Bag Party he was the
first golden buzzer we invited him on
now his song is going super crazy though
he's seen that innovator on yet no we
were just with Vader at the club yeah
yeah he about to come on he he uh
produced for him too yeah I feel like
Vader's got like a wave going like his
sound is like yeah it's kind of like if
you go to La he's the guy who you'll
hear his [__] yeah for sure I'd be
wondering how he'd be having all those
samples and I don't know if he's
clearing them there's no way yeah like
the uh we had that whole dialogue on the
show he's not clear yeah I mean he's not
clear with that yeah hey but good for
him hey he's gonna get that distro kid
check as long as he can until they come
through and they're like hey but so when
we talk about impact though like when we
going out to all these events and
talking to the artist because there's
been artists that have we've tried to
get him on the show but they've said oh
we charge and we've pulled up to them in
person this is what I would say
if anybody tells me I've only had one
person trying to charge me to do an
interview actually I take that back too
one of them was Crick Mac and it was 500
and I was like you know what I paid 500
just to hang out with [__] Mack and
record it whatever we didn't we haven't
done anything yet yeah the other one was
ban man Kevo
try to charge me 10 grand and I just
said LOL I'll pass yeah
yeah it has his people reach out trying
to get bottles at my club last week
because he was in Arizona I'm like are
you gonna be [__] up bro bottles
um
but when I say so so like that's a
couple people that I try to charge too
but those people I feel like so I think
you guys pretty much are spot on because
when I see impact I'm like okay to me I
think of like DJ head goes and sits in
the studio with these artists and helps
like big bank from YG I'm not sure that
song comes out without DJ head like but
that's not a podcast that's you do your
head on his own true but it's a DJ head
on its own it's not it's not it's fair
enough it's not a podcast that's fair
they have different accolades and I
think being spread out I don't know
that's a fit like you said and that's
like where the brands are kind of spread
Chuck sometimes does interviews on his
own at the radio station I I get the
that's like saying me and Jr are in the
studio with like blueface and making
records with all these artists and the
podcast has more impact yeah that's fair
um yeah I mean I think you guys got a
lot of this shoe but again I am not
I don't want to sit here and be like you
guys are right because I'm not hip to a
lot of this [__] yeah like don't Dom and
doe you said it's for most uh no no but
what I'm saying yeah from Orange County
but from what you do know it's fair
from the things you do yeah I mean I
mean I would probably personally the
only thing I would probably change on
here if I had to change something
um I think that the day in La dude
probably deserves a little uh I feel
like he's extremely he feels even though
I don't agree with most of the things
that he says like what
uh he's just approached to radio and
like he's he's honestly beefing with
head so had he said some [__] about head
that's crazy
um which you know Master boy huh that's
your boy that's like the most selfless
[__] alive yeah and he's been
pushing this La line for I don't know
but I heard from what I heard it had to
be biased with some people though yeah
from I heard like he's kind of a
gatekeeper why do you think that is I
mean bias I wouldn't say heads biased I
think no but why do you think okay you
in the radio too why are you guys in 25
cities every day so yeah yeah okay but
why do you do you ever like reach out to
other upcoming artists like the whole
West Coast scene like yes I mean I'm
trying to get DB to come DB by the back
I've been trying to get him on the show
for like six months so let me ask you
what do you think is wrong without Russ
trying to get him Russ hat Russ has us
on his tour he's stopping by in L.A he's
putting us on the media pass so we're
going to be the only media platform
covering that tour when he's in L.A
think about the DB one yeah yeah he's
come we're doing his release party so
we're going to be covering the release
and Russ has him pulling up to our
podcast as one is a stop so always I
think if you're gonna be a um
if you're going to be a platform that I
think it should be kind of like your
duty to try to help up and coming
artists so if you watch my [__] you'll
notice I'll have artists that not a lot
of people know but I just happen to
think they're dope and then I'll have
artists everybody knows yeah yeah so
it's like yeah you know for me it's like
part of what I'm I think that's that's
the wow factor it's important because
like I had dusto dub on and when I had
dusto on the internet went crazy my
numbers shot up right and then right
after that we're bringing regular people
on but it makes people feel like [__] I
could be a part of that too that's the
power of yeah and regular people yeah we
have like um
trying to think
it's I mean dude I mean I tapping with
you I mean do I have the Russell on the
podcast like two and a half years ago
yeah you know before everybody was like
uh on them yeah so for me it's like I'm
always just like hey if someone's dope
and I see what they're doing like dude
that Mexican OTS going crazy right now
yeah and then I had a moment on the show
where I was like dude I dm'd you
a year and a half ago you hit me back
he's like no way and I'm like he's like
oh [__] yeah you know so for me it's
like you gotta kind of even in here in
La like dude I've tried to pretty much
show love to everybody I [__] with in La
so what do you think is the problem out
here like just I supported John and I'm
talking about podcasts the artist right
now
um why do you think the West Coast Music
Scene because I produce I'm a DJing I
see what do you think why are we why are
we not selling out here why is it not
going crazy in the west right now I
would say the following
if you the answer is already there
if you look at the artists who have
worked from LA
in the last let's say 10 years right
Kendrick Lamar Schoolboy Q
Rowdy Rich blast IG
tattoo sign and you just go to up and
down the list right
um
none of those guys music at a certain
point in time every single one of those
people
showed the ability to make records that
were bigger than what is perceived to be
the Los Angeles sound
so if you think about YG
YG
Toot It and booted
was was definitely like a snapshot into
the LA sound at that time
but what really changed YG's life
was my hitter with Jeezy and Rich Homie
Quan right because that kind of busted
open the whole country for him and then
what did he do he put out one of the
best albums of the last 10 years a
classic My Crazy Life is like the type
of music that is
undeniable so if you're putting out
undeniable levels of Music quality you
could put it in the Rafters next to good
kid Mad City and doggy style and get
rich or die trying it's it's it's that's
the level of music you need to make so
you think artists are making that no out
here I think that people are making good
good la music what do you think about
like the whole Soak City shout out 3.0
baby like that Detroit West Coast bounce
I think the Detroit [__] I mean I think
like you said like all that [__] is cool
but at the end of the day
is that [__] a snapshot into what's
going on right now
is it Timeless so you think that there's
your question is is is is you should ask
yourself because this is why I always
tell everybody make timeless music
Timeless means if you listen to it in 10
years it's still gonna work right
is Lil Vader making timeless music
probably not is he making it might be
though because his samples so it might
be no it might be that what I'm saying
is he making it is he making hot records
for the west coast to play in the club
[__] yeah but is that [__] if you play
it back in 10 years 15 years or people
gonna be like yo you like think about
the jerks we really don't know to be
honest I feel like this generation we
don't know but what I'm saying is this
right like timeless music always
prevails for the for the next uh
uh Ty Dolla Sign makes Timeless do you
think it was for that time though like
don't you think the kids now that are
growing up these high schoolers like
people say oh they're making high school
music it's just Tick Tock
[__] right but that was an error though
it was error but do you hear people
playing I'm a jerk in the club anymore
no no
do you hear people playing Dreams and
Nightmares in the club still yes I see
what you're saying I see what you're
saying hey think about some L.A [__]
Ballin by Roddy rich and mustard that
record will always be played even if
it's a part of your opening set that
record is getting played in the club now
I might not get played every night but
that record is timeless when you break
that down what do you think about a
Timeless record is the production or
just the song I mean we're talking about
I mean look at I mean who's the biggest
La rapper in the last 20 years it's
Kendrick Lamar
Kendrick Lamar is making
the highest level of hip-hop you can
make right like it's just it's just like
a lot of people weren't really [__]
with his album whose album you talking
about where he sold out the Staple
Center no but it was just like it was
just kind of a weird album I mean I
don't think I thought it was brilliant
like how often do you listen to that
album a lot for real 100 first of all
Kendrick Lamar EP
is a [__] classic all right so if you
think back to when Dre shouted him out
yeah on Big Boys neighborhood yep
and then
Kendrick dropped that free I think was
the watch out for detox freestyle Am I
Wrong what the [__] was the name of that
[__] I think it was a watch out for
detox freestyle
the thing about Kendrick Lamar is
Kendrick Lamar is like maybe the
greatest rapper of all time so like
again we're talking about he's an alien
yeah yeah right like he's an alien yeah
so like you like he's an alien talented
person who's just making music to live
to yeah right he's not just sitting
there rapping in One Tone like this
Kendrick uses his voice as a tool I
would say Kendricks some rappers that
find a formula and they just stick to
that on every song and you could take it
and put it on any song and it'll work
out only lasts something yeah but what
I'm saying is with Kendrick he doesn't
have that you don't know what he's gonna
I mean because Kendrick's yeah yeah one
of the greatest rappers of all time so
so if you like so to me the La dilemma
is our La artists making a real
conscious effort to make
like [__] that works now [__] that'll be
here forever you say la do you know IE
has a ton of plethora even the Bay Area
San Diego yeah I'm tapped in with all
that [__] yeah I mean eyes
I don't think artists are thinking that
deep into it I think a lot of these
Street artists are just having fun we
just had a we just had a cam Archer on
the show he's from San Bernardino all
right we got to stop the interview real
quick tell you about our folks at my
bookie our partners at my bookie man
listen football season is approaching it
is preseason right now I can feel it
just had my first Fantasy Draft it's
time to get this [__] money NFL is
here go to mybookie.ag right now sign up
for a new account use the promo code
bootleg right now when you sign up
they're gonna give you that first
deposit bonus now my book is crazy
because no matter where you're at you
can go on and get in on some of that NFL
action you can get on some of that
baseball action you can get in on their
Live casino
Blackjack rule let slots whatever you're
into it's going down mybookie.ag all
right sign up right now with that promo
code bootleg they're gonna hook you up
real nice first deposit bonus free money
to gamble with bro when you sign up what
are we talking about football season is
here this is literally my favorite time
of the year as a degenerate we must
participate we got to get a little
action in every Sunday on something
maybe a little Thursday night football
action maybe a little preseason action
who do you think's gonna win the Super
Bowl throw a hundred on it [__] it sign
up mybookie.ag use that promo code
bootleg and they're going to get you
hooked up with that first deposit bonus
also want to give a big shout out to our
family at King Palm man want to give a
shout out to kingpong they have the um
sugar Sean
first of all congratulations to Phoenix
Arizona's own sugar Sean for just
winning that title with UFC they did a
collab with them
uh these are the sugar punch honey
orange pre-rolls which are gas all right
now this was dope about King Palm 100
organic all right we're talking about no
tobacco organic leaves and what's dope
is they have these terpene infused tips
that people just love bro they're called
the flavor tips right you're like uh you
bust one of these boys out you know what
I'm saying you fill it with your stuff
whatever you want to smoke some of that
flour that you got from Jardine
and then you hit the tip
and man oh I just tasted it right now
just flavor full of Flavor now go to
kingpom.com right now use the promo code
bootleg and you're gonna get half off
whatever's on kingpop.com if you don't
know King Palm is everywhere go to your
local smoke shop go to your local
7-Eleven they got King Palms everywhere
so many flavors
so many Vibes the grapes are gas
yo kingpom.com use the promo code
bootleg 50 off let's get back to the
interview the thing about Atlanta and
the South and Memphis tell them you tell
me they are the sound of hip-hop so it
used to there was a pocket in time when
the sound was mustard beats do you think
it's the tempo the 100 bpms
I feel like I feel like ASM needs a
crossover record and over in order for
it to make I mean because I like the way
you move it's like his biggest record
right blueface got on the remix right
um I just think like we gotta understand
like one
if you're like Roddy Rich did such a
good job of coming in and just making
records like if there were crossovers no
but if you listen there were a crossover
but if you listen even if you listen to
like
uh like listen to racks in the middle
that's 80 bpms that's an 80 BPM record
that's not a 102 BPM record you know
what I'm saying if you listen to the box
that's [__] uh 58 BPS one of my YG
records is toxic right a [__] amazing
record amazing record right but it's
it's like it's a crossover record it's a
commercial it's not but that records
being played everywhere yeah but that's
what I'm saying I I feel like once ASM
gets one of them type records a
crossover record then it's then it'll
read but you gotta understand like are
you making music for you and your homies
and you and where you're from are you
making music for the [__] hey he's
just having fun yeah yeah and guess what
and to me that's okay yeah because I
love la music so I like West Coast music
but I also can understand that like
there's certain music that has a ceiling
yeah you know what I'm saying and that's
why I appreciate like someone like G
Perico he kind of goes out of his way to
kind of
do different [__] yeah like he's rapping
on different styles of Beats not
everything sounds like uh the way Jeep
Rico should sounded five years ago like
he's doing like his gangster girls is
[__] shout out shout out uh what's
his name steals yeah still his producer
I feel like they locked in and created
us they created a sound like that's like
his 40. that is though like very
important in the west coast do you think
it's a lot of producers or a lot of B
makers because who's really locking in
with these artists going to the studio
sessions no there's a lot of beat makers
for sure but producers are like you said
you got to kind of like yeah like steals
a producer yeah
does he Stills come up and how he
started and where he's at now it's like
yeah you're the Superstar it wasn't all
these artists like think about all right
yeah we're talking about Roddy Rich
right yeah Die Young was a song that was
before please excuse me for being
anti-social right Die Young
is a record that if you're still in the
club you could just drop the hook get in
and out of that [__] that record is 82
bpms
so it's like and guess what then nle
Choppa had to go and get him a Roddy
hook on a 82 BPM record walk him down is
crazy and that's what that's to do from
the south who was like I gotta tap in
with Roddy Rich yeah so at the end of
the day right now think about blast
everyone if you look at NAS it's got
blast on his albums Rick Ross got blast
doing hooks like Ty Dolla Sign was one
of those guys where he listened to Ty
you might be like oh this is the
greatest artist to ever live if you
listen to some of his albums like
there's no box you could put Ty dollar
sign in because Ty is focused on making
timeless music and if it's but Ty is
like a musician he picks a guitar he
makes Beats but he's an alien yeah but
that's all I'm saying he's not just but
he's focused on times these other
artists were talking about they just
think about this make me like they just
write like I remember the YG mixtape era
yeah and the pushes Inc [__] and
things started to change
when
the music became
more of a priority for those guys
because you can look on YouTube I have
an interview I'm interviewing Ty Dolla
Sign Bobby Brackins and YG at the same
time and at that time Bobby Brackins was
the most popular and those guys Ty's
always been so musically like inclined
that like it was just a matter of time
right and YG his everyone's
when he was on the double XL cover with
the big YG chain people were like why is
he on this cover yeah he got one record
two to the booted people didn't
understand it right but what happened
was he put out a classic album his first
album is a literal classic and it
changed the way
everyone in the country looked at YG
because after that you got YG mustard
and Ty on the [__] cover of the
source together you know what I'm saying
like it just it just kind of stamped
like do you think in every team
everybody has their own moments to shine
like do you think this is leapfrog with
like a lot of these camps that are
moving together well I think Atlanta and
the South have honestly had um hip-hop
in a Stranglehold for like 20 years so
the south is kind of like like right now
it's like Memphis you know like Memphis
Atlanta Alabama but just that whole
region just has
I mean they're not let go of rap for
you think the politics also holds back
uh music collaborations collab yeah for
sure so say like an artist oh that's
this artist club with this artist
especially in L.A do you think a
producer could change that and just have
a hook from him and a verse from him and
just make the song and drop it what do
you think about that but I think that
that could be like you would have to
have both of them co-sign it and you
know that's the only that's another
thing that's unfortunate about La is
like sometimes like that's why I like
some of the younger dudes like one take
Jay and like AZ chike you know trikes
had his issues with the
with Draco and the Ingle weird [__] or
whatever
um but I think that the younger dudes in
La have at least made a real con
concerted effort to like work together
what do you think is hindering them like
the once AJ AZ child I mean I think
they're making cool music but they just
gotta make better music
like make better music good mids nah
this [__] is good it's good West Coast
[__] like Iowa so it's always good out
here one of my favorite rappers like I
love ruchi's albums I loved him and
trike's album yeah but like I'm a fan of
West Coast music shout out Ruchi I feel
like Ruchi is one of those guys where
he's he has good music but his
personality rolls into his branding the
best and it's just like you know why
people love Ruchi ruchi's the best yeah
we went after our season finale we went
with Ruchi to Keynes yeah and we took
over Kane's ruchi's the best crazy
personalities watch the season finale of
most of Mondays on leak podcast and you
will understand why Ruchi is a West
Coast staple and why so let me say this
about Ruchi right ruchi's a smart kid
man and and and I think somebody who's
doing [__] kind of like the right way
since he broke away from our nation is G
Perico I think he's a great example of
any La artist can look and see the
amount of shots he puts up he's putting
out hella [__]
product and he's not afraid to jump on
different beats and do different [__]
and whether or not he catches a
quote-unquote hit is one thing but the
fact that he's able to take Ruchi out on
a national tour like they went on on a
national [__] tour in New York in
Atlanta in DC and did a tour off of what
G Perico has done the last three years
since he left Roc Nation so rushi to me
Ruchi is super smart and he's super
terrible was it Judah tell me that Ruchi
he's independent has bigger numbers than
these artists is the biggest independent
artist in LA right now
probably is they're both on Empire oh
Empire okay Empire they they're both on
the same what do you think about
um should artists drop drop drop or be
very slow with their drops I think if if
I'm independent and I'm a rapper
and I'm independent I'm dropping best
method drop every week drop every other
week what do that I can't tell you but
I'm I'm keeping that mixtapes are
singles what do you think I'll drop a
project out or just keep single single
single single if you don't have a
following drop singles if you have a
following what it what what what
dictates the following is there yeah is
there a certain number that this is what
you got to understand about Spotify
right yeah is Spotify is the biggest
okay right Spotify is if somebody from a
record label
they don't check Apple they go on
Spotify to see your monthly listeners
it's just the standard so when I say
Spotify I'm talking about whatever I
agree okay Apple music apply it to title
whatever
every time you do a release right it's
another push and impression to your
algorithm on your plate on your on your
profile right so if you don't have fans
and you put a 12 song album out that's
one impression that's one chance to get
break it up into hits so that's one
chance for you to get an audience with
this body of work that you put together
instead of you saying I could get 12
chances yeah right now if you're G
Perico and you got a built-in fan base
then yo just drop it yeah but where's
the middle ground and be like okay I
yeah because that's the extreme you
gotta have fans bro you'll know if you
have fans bro you'll know bro you'll
know if you got [__] buying all
your merch showing up and selling out
shows otherwise drop singles and build
that following because you're going to
build the following through singles how
do you get the fans I mean I don't know
bro what's the best way to just get that
girl following that you know you're
gonna be extremely one like you said
it's none of the difference because the
most important [__] is consistency yeah
right so if you if you pop out and you
got one record that does well but then
you don't do [__] after that or you do a
follow-up and then you get discouraged
because the follow-up didn't do just
keep throwing shots it's crazy is that
there's a lot of big artists in LA and
um
the reason I know this is because we've
they're they're with it to come on the
podcast but they're just like tucked
right now right they had success they
have big records and that's they're La
Staples oh this [__] is consistency yeah
but but but they I don't know if it's
Comfort I don't know if it's mental
health I don't know what it is but a lot
of these artists that were big they just
kind of go into hiding and take a couple
years off when you don't have that time
think about this think about oh Jeezy
he's on Atlantic right yeah yeah oh
Jeezy It's been just dropping
consistently since he left Shoreline
albums singles like oh Jeezy is
on the road consistently yeah he just
announced a new tour that sold out
before that he was on tour YG like
before that he was on his own tour it's
like consistency matters and it's super
serving like at the end of the day like
you gotta how long do you think an
artist could tuck after they drop like a
big body of work it depends on how big
we're talking but it's like if we're
talking like like big locally yeah or
like like Southern California regional
artists out here I think you know you
should drop three months later an album
for sure but I think [__] should
be dropping singles if you have a hit
how long do you write it out before you
drop something else like do you just
ride that here you can still drop
something else yeah while also pushing
the hit yeah it ain't like you can't do
both yeah so if you have a hit record
it's going crazy push that record but
then drop another record but I've heard
a lot of these these big La artists or
La artists that are over here usually
depends on like people's [__] like
they got new music they got new music
but all you hear is the old stuff that
works well the problem is is most people
will out think themselves out of a
career
overthink themselves people think too
much they they're worried about well I
don't like the way the video looks or
you know people overthink everything I
mean I see it every single day with just
people going close with who are artists
like bro why are you sitting on 50 songs
on your hard drive yeah because your
weights all go out if you're waiting for
the right time
when's the right time yeah like
I agree put some [__] music out bro
or they'll have managers or people like
these artists will have managers and
people that say oh we gotta do it this
way oh and I don't like that one like
they'll tell them oh I don't like that
song how are you gonna tell an artist
what they what's good that's the thing
is like in today's world everyone's got
a short memory bro so you might put a
song out and if your fans don't [__]
with it drop another one yeah we had a
girl on our show and she's like oh I
just started rapping so I'm not really
taking it serious and I said but if the
[__] went viral you would take it
serious like you're waiting too long to
take it serious you're waiting for it to
blow and then by the time it goes by the
time it goes crazy you're not even
prepared for the moment that's going to
be delivered to you I mean the problem
with like when when Perico was on Rogue
Nation bro they were just like
overthinking all his [__] they're like
we need a radio record and then they
would overthink it and then preco's like
bro as soon as he got out of that deal
with that [__] turned up yeah
and like the proof is in the pudding the
proof of concept is there it's like hey
bro like especially if you're like an
artist who you're like hey I know I make
fire west Coast Music right yeah so let
me just
make up for the fact that maybe I ain't
popping in Nebraska
but I'm popping from like New Mexico
over or like you know El Paso or over
whatever so let me just turn up and run
up the catalog you know what I'm saying
like we use an example a little like
little vein is like killing it you know
I mean he's getting he's running and
getting bags everywhere
it's like bro just keep turning up and
super serving your fans and if you catch
one that's bigger yeah it'll happen but
like at the end of the day like
unfortunately
for whatever reason
most of The Gatekeepers in hip-hop
aren't based in LA
right so there's that because you look
at like the double XL freshman cover
it's a it's a East Coast biased process
where they pick these artists yeah like
when we talk about these platforms
though you don't think there should be a
platform that should get to that
standard of the Excel is this is is
double xl's double XL that's just been
around for you yeah but see timing
the problem is yeah but see they but
they're they're not relevant outside of
that one cover every year but but yeah
and I understand this what we're trying
to do and the reason we're doing this
and pressing so hard and in everybody's
face we plan to be the new MTV the new
106 in part the new lower bill of the
music game of culture and more people
more people if if I'm not just trying to
sit on it
because if you think about La like we
need more platforms yeah because the
whole entire industry is is biased
against La yeah so you agree what we're
doing yeah no no no but you think we
need more no no I think the problem is
is I think the podcast game is getting
just as flooded yes I'm saying that this
music industry
is operating at all times yeah at a non
it's it's operating
with a non-la bias at all times because
most of the the labels and the big big
[__]
like if you think of like Adam right
Adam is probably the biggest platform in
in La him and Vlad right because vlad's
based here yeah but like I wouldn't
consider them like La platforms I would
say like atoms mostly known for popping
um like XXX and like little yachty and
like uh little Zan and like [__] like
that back then
right so it's like right now
you know if you think about
what's going on in New York there's the
Rap Radar [__] there's
Joe Budden uh noriegas in Miami drink
Champs in Atlanta you got a bunch of
academics is in New York so everybody
double excels in New York
um complex is a new york-based company
complexes
a media Juggernaut that is New York all
the people who work there for the most
part
they're New York kids so you're just
describing like all these people think
about forms out that way not out here no
no so what I'm saying is in the way that
like
New York drill [__] gets covered
nationally it'd be nice if they would
cover La [__] nationally like the same
but see but the problem is that the
platform's fault is that because there's
no platforms out here that are
knowledgeable I feel like well but I
feel like this I have a lot of friends
in Jersey in the east coast and [__]
like that and with everything we're
doing they [__] with heavy and you get
me and so for me it's I'm not like like
uh let's say for instance like the Fig
community and the community and there's
like a certain Street Lane that they
stay in yeah there's like a bubble with
what we're doing it's this is like I'm
not street I'm not Hood I'm none of that
[__] so like I said to be like the MTV
version of up to date and being that
platform if we're able to to get the the
artist to be uh uh to launch them out
and they're not looking at just the
artist but they're looking at the
platform who's doing it they will get
their shout out on that side of town but
they need a big platform under them to
be able to shout them out yeah I think I
think there's a few things right if you
really think about like guys who have
gotten like extremely huge uh notoriety
recently who are from the West Coast
yeah
um it's because they're doing something
different who are they the Russell
Russell's been on every podcast
to play Devil's Advocate
the Russell's Lane is live performances
and his music it's I mean but he's bro
he's got faith I mean I'm not saying he
doesn't no no no he's got fans off of
his music yeah yeah yeah yeah because
I've seen this man announce thousand
percent a thousand percent I'm not
denying his greatness I'm not denying
the people that are short enough for him
and stuff like that but what I'm saying
is it's like uh uh uh uh people that
freestyle have a hard time making radio
records you get me in so his music Just
Hits a little bit different his Lane is
live performances I wouldn't say that
his bars his bars when his live
performances you just feel it it's like
oh [__] people connect to me but when
you hear the song on a regular MP3 mix
and mastered and all that stuff the
Russell's records don't hit the same but
my point is
this is
who's getting National like the
Russell's whole approach to this [__]
he changed the music yeah he changed the
game for sure so he's been getting
exposure on every platform that's not so
the problem is but what's all on the
rate not radio what song What MP3 of his
is going crazy you're just saying that
because he's different though that's why
you get the bag that's just hard no no
but like the MP3 version of the live
version because the live version goes a
lot crazy stream the stream I mean I was
in the Russell [__] he puts an album
every month I mean the rest was doing
numbers on Spotify I'm not saying that
he's not but what I'm saying is the the
what he's doing is building a community
and building a cult following like we've
never seen while also changing music and
that's why that like I and I'll I'll
give credit to the Russell right now
there's a lot of people that were scared
to like bring people to my crib and do
this and all that seeing what he did it
gave me the battery to have people pull
up yeah I was like he's doing it
yeah let's do it like it's possible so I
would say like you know it's important
to like you know a lot of these um
bigger companies like complex or Amazon
like Amazon uh a lot of the people who
are running [__] at Amazon now are La
folks so you'll see like Amazon will
probably start showing more attention
through rap rotation and Amazon music to
La artists because a lot of the folks
pulling the strings on the Amazon music
side are La folks so you'll notice
that'll change yeah um so it's just a
matter of like but for me like even like
a lot of this young La sound right now
the moment I hear click click bang bang
boom it's just like all right bro now I
appreciate everybody having fun and and
I think like you asked like how can la
music kind of take over more it's like
West Coast not just west coast just make
better music
good music I can show you some great
music from the iei artist that nobody's
Shining Light on the IE right now I
don't know why it's l-a-l-a-l-a-l-a uh
thisler got the bay area but I.E has
tons of talent yeah nah I mean San
Bernardino Rancho Cucamonga Moreno
Valley even in Oceanside uh Desi Hollows
fire yeah you know do the damn thing
from San Bernardino yeah I heard of them
what's the other kid um who we tried to
interview like three times but he just
no showed every time he kept having [__]
nice from San Bernardino how do you feel
about no shows
um I mean it depends on who it is
honestly for real if like someone knows
shows
I guess a no-show is different than like
canceling yeah but if someone just knows
shows and I don't hear from them I'm
like well thanks no but like canceling
and you know it's [__] it happens
bro yeah but like the dude uh him busy
what do you think about him he Beezy he
no show three times on the podcast does
he have an interview here he's supposed
to do you know where he's from isn't he
from San Bernardino
what do you think do you think that he's
from San Diego he said that no where is
he from oh he's from somewhere over
there right I mean I've seen interviews
he's from La I guess I guess he's from
L.A
but uh what do you think about him easy
though like what do you think as far as
like him and the West Coast like how
he's he's getting played in like Florida
and they're thinking he's a Florida
artist and like from what I've seen at
least like they think he's a I'm not
educated enough National wild artist
type um speak on like what he's doing
because uh I heard his like a couple
records and I just thought they were
cool you know okay but why did you want
to bring him in because of those couple
records no he wasn't coming to Freestyle
like I I like to like if somebody's like
buzzing I like to have him come up and
rap you know yeah yeah
um but yeah no he was supposed to come
on here and and just he had like a car
break down and his man at one time his
manager was his him in a little beta of
the same manager yeah or they did
but uh his managers were here and they
were just waiting on him and just he
just had [__] pop up I eventually I'm
sure have him come up you know he was
supposed to come up and rap first when
we had Desta one we were all the team
got together everybody's like this was
coming audition or whatever I posted it
I had groupies pop up to the studio all
this [__] or whatever right
just because that Destin was coming then
he called and was like I got a flat tire
on the freeway or whatever I'm like are
you doing it like over there I can like
where you're from West Covina that's
that's where you yeah yeah [__]
that's a drive bruh yeah yeah no so but
I was like oh [__] here's the excuse
because I didn't meet him until that
interview right I thought it was
bullshitting and then I looked at the
story and I'm like oh he actually like
[__] his car up you feel me and so I
just feel like a lot of people take
things sensitive when you you guys I
don't think anything personal life is
life anything music related or industry
related I don't take any of this [__]
personal yeah is TG stood up and walked
out of an interview and I was like well
that was fun
whatever
I don't give a [__] but was the energy
aggressive when he walked out or was it
like it's just like weird but it wasn't
on no uh uh like it was just weird
massive aggressive all right bro it
wasn't like uh what's his name
um baby where he was like put some
respect on my name keep my name on the
[__] mom it wasn't like that uh it
wasn't aggressive but I don't think any
[__] personal bro I don't care about
another [__] [__] had bad days
these fools don't I don't care like I
literally don't care like you could have
gave me an f and I would not have I
wouldn't have commented I just wouldn't
well
we still be here right now no
one time
I honestly probably
um so the fact that you got
well I mean no not just did you know who
I am do you know who Yik Mike is do you
know you never know the records I made
or DJing or nothing okay gotta stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our good Folks at Blue true baby that's
right shout out to Blue true man listen
everyone's always asking me does blue
true work of course it works because it
has the same active ingredient as Viagra
and Cialis
it is Dick season out here bro you know
what I'm saying you got to make sure
that dick is up to par you know you get
on that blue shoe and uh you're gonna
never like I mean I'm gonna be honest
like
you remember when Barry Bonds hit 70
home runs in a season and now they're
not letting them in the Hall of Fame
like you get off that Bluetooth they're
not gonna let you in the dick Hall of
Fame because it's cheating to be honest
you know what I'm saying so
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
when you sign up now this is what's dope
about Bluetooth because you want to know
if it works well they're gonna send you
a month for free
free Bluetooth in discrete packaging
delivered right to your door but you
have to use the promo code bootleg
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
everything's online no doctor's office
visits no worrying about [__] having
a weird conversation with some [__]
about your [__] [__] no you
[__] bluetooth.com free month online
you don't even have to leave your
[__] apartment you don't have to
leave anywhere you just order it it
comes in the mail and then you know you
you just you know you get to work you
get to work all right so use that promo
code bootleg and get a free month of
blue chew also want to give a big shout
out to our good Folks at Odd Socks now
this is what's up about Odd Socks I'm
about to reach into my Odd Socks bag oh
man
look Odd Socks they got
all of the [__] sick licenses
recently they locked down Coca-Cola
recently they locked down [__]
Transformers Saban Power Rangers we got
Yoo-hoo we got Sour Patch Kids
you know they got their Odd Socks Basics
and I'm telling you the most comfortable
socks in the world in the [__] world
all right and they can all be yours 20
off
20 off using the promo code bootleg if
you go to
oddsoxofficial.com the most comfortable
socks in the world
and they got draws and these draws are
amazing these are this is this is a
small just so we're clear this is a
small yeah
yeah chicks can wear these you know a
lot of chicks like wearing these booty
shorts around the crib and [__]
oddsocksofficial.com whatever you're
into they got the license WWE Scarface
[__] Breaking Bad whatever
autosofficial.com promo code bootleg go
over there get 20 off right now let's
get back to the interview but I think
the bigger question is would you be open
to exploring the IE just as much yeah of
course how come you haven't What stopped
you yeah I actually like right now my
the what I want to do so I you know I'm
from Arizona so I've done uh uh Arizona
Cipher where I had like who I thought
because I I've had like my favorite AZ
artist coming out to LA we did a cipher
I did it with Tucson too yeah so my next
thing is to do San Diego
I.E yeah
the high desert like Victorville Apple
Valley see if there's anybody dope out
there you heard of Maddie ice uh I've
heard of them yeah yeah he's in Arizona
doing the big things with artists out
there
um let me ask you for as long you've
been doing radio and in the music scene
why have you not have already been
tapped in with the IE like a long time
ago and why isn't it
I'm just confused on why there's so
there's not no light in the eye right
who's the biggest artist ever rapper I
mean rapper r3s from out there Arthur's
pretty big I try to interview R3 and
what happened uh we got to work on he's
on 300.
because they got beef
okay girls love Dev I I don't know I
mean I've never heard girls of Deb's
music so I've heard the name but I don't
know his music but yeah and I'll be
paying attention so I'm like this game
on the show he told me about R3 and R3
was like barely bubbling and then okay
it went crazy is it safe to say Drummer
Boy is probably the most successful IE
artist that's independent right I would
say a hip boy okay hit boy but his boy
also is like Pasadena to like his dad
now he's Fontana okay so guess what he
everybody considers him an LA artist but
he's IU listen man I had everybody from
hs87 yeah boy's been on my show like 30
times yeah everybody from hs87 has I
mean back in the day when ages 87 was
like moving yeah dog my thing is is like
hey there's a dude named cam Archer from
San Bernardino I know cam Archer who to
me was like an alien level rapper
because I saw one of my well actually my
producer saw when this freestyle said it
to me I'm like cam Archer guess what
though can I see a question what makes
you care about artists I just like like
what intrigues you about it I mean I
just been bro my whole life has been
hip-hop yeah I know I just seen you post
that uh Happy Birthday to hip-hop and a
senior time my whole life man you were
young as [__] since I was five years old
my whole life's revolved around rap
music so you know for me I like if I'm
but the question cam Archer [__] came
across my my desk and I was like oh
that's crazy right like he's got to come
right so we just gotta come across you
yeah I
understand I got like [__]
nine businesses going on at the same
time bro yeah yeah so it's like
I like to discover new music but at the
same time like how much of it is but
what I'm asking is how much of it is a
business and just keeping it going and
how much of it like what actually
interests you about artists and bring
them in or what I do or or are you just
like this is what I do and this is I
don't know because this is like the
podcast is a great bag for me yeah but
like bro I don't need this [__] like I
don't need this [__] like I'm let me
have it but isn't this how you tap in
with the culture and figure out what is
West Coast that's what I'm saying I just
had this conversation with an interview
I did from the Netherlands and he's like
why what pushes his passion I just love
music yeah and you'll see me pushing a
lot of like the type of hip-hop I'm
really into right so if if it's cam
Archer cam Archer is crazy I'm like oh
your biased towards it if you like it
that's when you're gonna well this is
his platform I guess of course I like
somebody's [__] yeah and they might not
be popping I like you okay so come up
and show let me use help you out with my
plan so it's not just to open like oh I
see I believe in them or if it makes
sense if if if uh somebody is like hey
I'm working with this artist and I check
this [__] out and I'm like okay I see
what they're doing like maybe it ain't
for me but just if I only interviewed
people I was into
it would uh I would only interview like
12 guys yeah okay so if I see if I see
what someone's doing and I'm like okay I
see what they're doing listen like or I
think they might be interesting yeah
like there's artists who I love to talk
to who I might not necessarily love
their music but we have dope
conversations yeah yeah you know what
I'm saying so what about producers and
DJs though to me I mean I'm not
interviewing DJs unless they've like
contributed like crazy [__] to hip-hop
what about producers yeah I mean I'll
interview producers I had a boy on 30
[__] million times I'm working on
getting the Alchemists on right now like
is there a certain level of statue I've
had mustard on a bunch yeah I'm not just
interviewing a producer because you
gotta
on the show uh and Dupree uh before like
you know I've had guys on but like I'm
not just yo you can't tell me you
produced a blue face song and expect to
come and sit down with me I don't care
yeah just to be honest what is it what
is the uh I just don't give a criteria I
just have to care yeah to me when I
think of League of stars and Dupree and
Jane Ari I think of like an era of West
Coast music
they started these guys were a part of
that wave that's important in the
context of the historical conversation
of La rap so I would love to talk to
Dupree yeah and and jaynari and them
dudes about
just that era yeah can I ask you a
question how many people are in your ear
when you go outside too much my DMs are
a [__] terrible Place yeah I mean
dude I get sent [__] 30 40 50 100 times
a day you got security when you go out
no no no no no come and rob me bro no
not even no not Rob no no no no no no no
we're getting to a point nowhere I I
I've never had security I mean no we're
getting to a point right now where it's
not security for safety it's security to
keep people away yeah like the crazy
part about it is I don't care about none
of that [__] I mean look you can walk up
to me I'll talk no grabbing on you
though but when nobody when nobody can
say about me is that they ever came up
to me and I was like I never I'm not a
big timer I'm just like hey I'll talk to
anybody yeah okay there's talking I just
went to the big X the plug concert um
you'll say you'll talk to anybody until
you have a drunk person trying to tell
you I need to be on your podcast bro
cause I'm gonna say the crazy [__] I own
a nightclub bro do you hear all that
sounds like when I walk through my club
in Arizona everyone's easy yo put me on
the pocket no
right then and there yeah no DM me your
[__] and if I get around to it I'll
check it out but no yeah like I'm not
just D I'm not just putting you on my
plan because I met you at a club just
because so hey so I don't give a [__] so
so it's a general census hollowing out a
podcast or the club isn't the move
what do you hope to achieve no I know I
just want the audience to know no so
Halloween at a podcaster to get on the
podcast in public is not the place to do
it no people want me to play their songs
on the radio and it's unmix mastered and
tell them dirty it's like baby wanted me
to send they sent me music and it's like
bro you really want me to play this at
this type of party I'm on the radio
every single day in 25 cities yeah la
Vegas Miami Tampa uh [__] Phoenix
Tucson Madison Wisconsin Flint Michigan
every single day four hours a day I'm on
the radio right now you're gonna get in
your car at seven in 20 minutes you'll
hear the you'll hear the bootleg caption
real 92.3 as soon as you get in that car
so
[__] like what if I don't owe you [__]
like what I'm trying to I'm gonna play
some [__] it's gonna be some [__] that
makes sense bro you got to compete
against Drake on these Airwaves
[__] you think I'm gonna play
your local rap [__] yeah that's not how
this [__] works yeah it's a business you
know what I'm saying anyway well look go
uh watch the YouTube channel Mondays and
Wednesdays right um they could check
this oh yeah money oh it's not Instagram
Instagram live uh IG live oh actually
yeah so look motion Mondays was on
YouTube you could go see all the motion
Mondays we have uploaded we're now
changing the game right now we're the
only podcast right that I've seen that
is going live on Instagram that looks
like full production with these mics and
cameras and everything we have a whole
vertical display that goes straight to
Instagram live so you have YouTube and
Instagram live simultaneously yes we're
on yes it's worth IG and the YouTube
channels people go liq podcast leak
podcast not liquid looking [__] it's the
link podcast like wet like water like
that [__] there it is you can check out
the report card and when we say we got
an A plus you got to think about it
we're innovating we're creating dialogue
with anybody above
about Plus
just name another podcast for one we
could just get who's going on Instagram
live Monday Wednesday with the setup the
display everything you can't answer that
question is
deeper than just a microphone There's
real art yeah we're producers DJs
Engineers we make music we're actually
artists but it's not just music we're
creating the the look of the podcast
we're creating the brand and doing all
that photoshop [__] we're not going to
Fiverr and paying somebody we're making
our own drip and wearing it Fly we're at
the parties we're looking Saucy drip the
artists that are at the clubs and
parties are at we're having more motion
and more people trying to be way crazier
than Balenciaga right yeah we're next to
these rappers that don't know how to
wear Balenciaga and yeah let the
designer wear them instead designers
we're the new lower bills the new
streetwear brand of the Inland Empire
SoCal NorCal whatever you want to say
the [__] I.E man shut up shout out to
the IE man I just had to tell Kev
Reckless man it's going crazy
know it or not produce producing crazy
it's all DJ Eric uh uh Justin girls love
they have the Artistry out there is
going crazy Morgan C it's going crazy
right now is this is a wave that's
coming up the young kids they got it the
youngins they got it hey I got number
left I'm on the right I'm on the radio
uh I gotta get you hip Kev I gotta get
you hip yeah I'm like Mike this is what
I do I'm in the culture I'll tell you
what you give me a list of 10 artists
who
can rap okay let me ask you this okay do
a cipher okay well ten of them we're
gonna do they got a rap yes they can't
[__] around they got to be able to okay
and I gotta ask you this question his
ears are good yeah I got I Engineer and
all that range real producer but I gotta
ask you this when you look at artists do
you does the look do you think the look
hinders them or if they can just have a
crazy flow crazy voice yeah if you think
the image hinders I don't know bro
there's there's no writing or you not
look at that stuff that doesn't matter
there's no right answer no no we're
looking we're not looking for a right
answer we're looking not because there's
examples of people who you would not
think are have have an image that pop
they're people who don't have Star
Quality they become Stars oh there's no
exact science yeah I'm just saying that
because I hear a lot of I'm just saying
that because I hear a lot of people
saying oh if you don't look the part
just because you can have you can be
talented and have all this and that but
if you don't look the part I mean you
should you're not gonna be able to get
right out of the way to look like [__]
you know like you should look
representable if you're an artist you're
a product what everyone needs to
understand is you
and your music
both of you are products yup the image
right yep no you're a product you're a
product that's image though right I mean
it's a part of it so the image your
image might even be that you are like
you're the product you're homeless
understand you're the product yes but
you are a product that is being sold
make no money understand your product if
you do not look at yourself like a
product and you're [__] yep
because this is the music business this
is not the music Community Club it's
business you're a product your music is
a product your live show is a product
you don't look at it as as I'm a product
then you're [__] yeah who cares about
your [__] Talent type [__] there's a
lot of so Talent you think talent
doesn't work it's all about hard work
there's a lot of talent to people what
do you think I know talented are I know
alien level talented [__] that
you'll never know about because they're
lazy as [__] they're lazy and they're
they think that they're entitled because
they're so good I hear a lot like
talents of people think oh I'm so good
this is Muse that you ain't got to put
in the words
you could be talented all you want if
you ain't willing to [__] get over
yourself and put the work in then you're
[__] it's like an agenda that people
that have talent they have like oh all
these people are I'm not I'm better than
them and all right well good luck man
have fun being talented in your bedroom
listen I appreciate you guys pulling up
the leak podcast uh Mondays and
Wednesdays check out their live streams
man
hey what up man uh you just watched
another episode of the blue black cat
podcast brought to you by hard Dean baby
shout out to the family at hardean don't
forget
make sure if you're in Las Vegas you get
into that taxi as soon as you land you
get into that Uber say take me to
hardine all right they're gonna take get
you taken care of the most craziest
Premium Selection of cannabis you'll
ever find Under One Roof it's a vibe in
there the bud tenders they're gonna take
care of you man listen tell them I sent
you they're gonna get you right shout
out to the family at hardine in Las
Vegas the number one dispensary in the
world all right and we are so proud to
be partners with them so shout out to
hardine go follow them online Hardy and
underscore Las Vegas and check out their
website hardinglasvegas.com get you some
swag you know you can't buy this but you
know yeah shout out to hardine